cette localité il nous a été demandé de
ne pas la nommer elle est à portée des
roquettes russes
les hauteurs nord-ouest de barmut après
des mois à reculer à l'intérieur et aux
alentours de la cité ravagée la 57e
brigade vient de mener sur ses flancs
quelques persil pas de triomphalisme
pour autant les taux est un peu desserré
4 km² de regagner mais par contre est
quand même tombé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sont désormais en première ligne
chose
pour le commandement ukrainien le
retrait s'est déroulé de façon contrôlée
ordre a été donné de prendre possession
des positions en surplomb de s'y
retrancher et de pilonner sans relâche
les lignes russes en contrebas
nous avons accompli notre mission à
barmouth nous avons concentré la
puissance de feu de notre ennemi sur nos
troupes alors est-ce que ça va être plus
dur maintenant pour nous oui mais nous
n'allons pas abandonner nous détruisons
maintenant l'artillerie ennemie et
détruisons leur formation de combat et
leur inffanterie
nous allons tenir la ligne autant que
possible et essayer d'attaquer darkmouth
sera comme un os coincé dans leur gorge
la mort qui vient du ciel la terreur des
soldats dans cette guerre chaque Coran
scrute les mouvements de l'adversaire
dans les chambrés armes munitions et le
nécessaire pour parer à toute
éventualité depuis le poste de direction
des opérations équipés d’étrangers
défilent les images filmées de drones
d'observation
nous avons besoin de nos drones pour
repérer les missiles guidées antichard
car nous pourrons alors amener notre
infanterie dans leur tranchée les hommes
scrutent les cartes d'état-major par
contre-attaque successives la volonté
est d'envelopper l'ennemi en attendant
la contre-offensive et faire de
darkmouth pour ceux qui en revendiquent
la victoire une souricière loin d'être
un revers pour les forces ukrainiennes
barboutes aurait rempli sa mission
épuisée et éliminée un maximum de force
pro Kremlin désormais bien installé sur
les hauteurs de la cité les forces
ukrainiennes envisagent un encerclement
tactique
quelques instants plus tard les
répliques russes au bombardement
Ukrainiens du matin ne se font pas
attendre il est temps de partir il a 57e
brigade a essuyé un feu nourri dans les
heures qui ont suivi